previously on
young sheldon i've been corresponding
with dr john sturgis at east texas tech
he said i could audit his course
i'm john sturgis sheldon invited me to
dinner
spaghetti and hot dogs is delightful
you're only here temporarily that's the
plan for now but
i could be enticed to stay
i do believe there were subtext there
did you pick up on it
oh thank you lord for connecting us with
the parents of another special child
you kids are special too
do you feel special at least i'm the
only daughter
you got nothing
[Music]
what grade are you in eight
you 10 well
nobody asked but fourth
why do grown-ups do this they love to
stick random kids together and expect
them to just be friends
i know i hate that fresh prince is right
parents just don't understand i love
that
song i have a cassette of it but i
recorded it off the radio
you can hear sean in the background
saying stuff about sir isaac
neutron ugh my sister's always talking
about him
i don't know why i think he's dead
you have no idea how much it sucks to
have a brother like him
believe it or not he's in my class my
parents sent paige to a private school
cool we're too poor for that
[Music]
does sheldon make you feel stupid
yeah i'm smart in other ways me too
hey i saw an old tv in the alley won't
go throw rocks at it
help yeah
dang it the scream won't break bad it'll
break if we blow it up
fine you're right erica is doing just
great nothing to worry about there
[Music]
come on
you got any matches be right back
why she's gone you want to make out
sure fine but one more that's it
[Music]
out there in check
[Music]
you